so right over here figure b is a scaled
copy of figure a and what we want to do
is figure out what is the scale factor
to go from figure a to figure b pause
the video and see if you can figure that
out
well all we have to do is look at
corresponding sides and think about how
much they have been scaled by
so for example this side right over here
would correspond to this side right over
here on figure b
and over here it had length two and over
here it has length one two three four
five six
so it looks like that side has been
scaled up by a factor of three and so if
this and if figure b truly is a scaled
copy then every side should be scaled up
by a factor of three and we could verify
that we don't have to do it with every
side we're being told that these are
scaled copies but we can see that this
is the case for example this side right
over here corresponds to this base right
over here
this has length three so if we're
scaling up by a factor of three
we should multiply that by three and
this should be of length nine let's see
if that's the case one two three four
five six
seven eight and nine and so you can see
we we can feel pretty good that figure b
is a scaled copy of figure a and that
scaling factor is three
let's do another example
so here we are told ismail made a scaled
copy of the following quadrilateral he
used a scale factor less than one all
right
and then they say what could be the
length of the side that corresponds to a
d so a d is right over here a d has
length 16 units in our original in our
original quadrilateral
what could be the length of the side
that corresponds with a d on the scaled
copy of the quadrilateral so it's a
scale factor less than one so
we're going to get something that is
less than 16 for that side and the rest
of it will
all be scaled by the same factors so the
resulting quadrilateral might look
something
might look something like this this is
just my hand-drawn version so the key
realization is is if our scale factor is
less than 1 this thing right over here
is going to be less than
16 units so let's look at the choices
and it says choose three answers
so pause the video which of these would
match if we're scaling by a factor of
less than one
well we just have to see which of these
are less than 16 units this is less than
16 this is less than 16. this is less
than 16. and those are the only three
that are less than 16.
32 units this would be a scale factor of
2 64 units this would be a scale factor
4 clearly a scale factor that is not
less than 1.